[Music]
I can't work under these conditions I
bet Ken Burns and I've had the deal with
no scraper's coming through
they say write what you know
so I'm gonna film one I know
like this Miss Gloria planting corn in
the middle of East Oakland
she used to spray me with that hose if
she caught me skipping school
cold-blooded
ah and here's the future stars of the
pac-10
Ricky he's got a nice arm
still needs to work on his aim
home sweet home
or then a lot of folks got these days
over here we're all Oakland natives
just some of us a little more native
than others
I'm talking thousands of years and my
people live what's up man I've been
looking for you
sure it's all there
you're good Drew I trust you
just check your West
I'm already late I don't want to be
short
all right one second
[Music]
you're good bro
how's your Auntie doing the medical
cover all our expenses or what
what the hell is this you guys are
hiking up the rent again I can't afford
another 500 a month
[Music]
500
what
out of all the relatives in the world I
get stuck with a [ __ ] slumlord for a
brother
oh little bro
my favorite starving artist
tell you I started hunting
it's a mouth meet in your life bro and
just hold yourself bro can you please
explain what the [ __ ] this is
this is about investing for the future
you've been stuck in the past too long
though bro
we can't get stuck here too come on Ken
this is Gloria Drew I mean it's still a
[ __ ] pandemic in case you haven't
noticed
people can't pay rent like that
nope
when they can't that's when we flip the
building goodbye section eight [ __ ]
hello luxury condos
come on man so you're for real for real
estate
no more scraping by Wes
I'm talking Building Wealth
real generational wealth
just like these white folks do
they don't give us land back we charge
every Tech bro 3 500 a month to live on
our original land our
man this is a lonely land dumbass
you know what I'm saying man
the only problem is I'm not trying to
get tied up in court with all this
that eviction band they did is up but I
can't be dealing with no ACLU lawsuits
you know I got those issues yeah
those illegal building permits right
charges for Bradman local officials
robbery charges
you know none of that [ __ ] ever sticks
to me
but I don't need more heat
oh
and I'll do it
what
sign over control of the bone to me
pops they give it to us what 50 50.
you just make it 51.49 for me
but I'll make sure you get your profit
back without any backlash
you serious
damn
I didn't know my little bro was carrying
in Big Medicine bundles like that okay
my man
should you have enough money to make
your movies now yeah
first one I'll make is a scandalous
documentary about you
get my notary I'll sign everything
tomorrow morning
where
dad used to tell us growing up that if
you keep anything in the family long
enough become sacred
keep people in the land together
well
we need each other
I'm not saying that this is our
traditional homelands
but it's the only home that we've known
[Music]
hey there he is
right there
right over there
yeah nothing like a good old treaty
signing brokered by a white man
what can go wrong right you almost
smudge them say General for protection
plan Lord
[Music]
land lord
like Lords of the land
native people can't be Lords
dad knew that
the only reason that we're in this mess
is because some British Lords stole it
and then some Cowboy stole it from those
Lords so they can Lord over it as new
Lords
[Music]
this is where it says you got control
but we split any profits 50 50.
this is what they've been doing to us
all along
divide conquer split the difference
I can't kick anyone out like that
can I
[Music]
one last page
we need you to decide this one here the
bloodline
foreign
[Music]
the [ __ ] is this
one dad's out over the building to me
sounded in blood
isn't mine
now it's your turn
Traditions matter
what if I don't have to charge any damn
rent
[ __ ] maybe I can get glory on everyone
else to own it with me on some Urban res
Co-op [ __ ]
I'm not saying we'll be one big happy
tribe living off the land in indigenous
Turtle Island Harmony
but [ __ ] it if we can't take it all back
we could at least switch up this little
piece of land
right
when he finds out I didn't a victim
that's it between us
thou be it in blood
[Music]
but what would he even do wouldn't it be
hella rich rich
nah
take all the blood from my heart
if he wants to come for me
let him
but we're brothers
and he's gonna have to decide we all do
how to live in this new world
I'm not talking about the [ __ ] that
Columbus found I'm talking about the
ones we made out of the mess we found
ourselves together and Against All Odds
Against disease since the beginning
but this time
this time we can make it ours
unlord the land unlord all the [ __ ]
they've been lording over us like like
we can't dream bigger than the American
dream like like we can't wake up if we
decided we had to
what you waiting for
come on bro you scared or what
[Music]
[Applause]